there was nobody worse qualified than me
to be and then I was just a regular
messed up person pursuing all the same
sort of messed up things that other
people pursue and God doesn't call
people who are equipped he equips those
that he calls my legal name is Claudette
Monika Powell my religious name is
sister Monica Claire Powell and with the
community of st. John Baptist in Mendham
New Jersey July 8th it'll be seven years
the calling that I felt to be a nun
started completely out of left field
I remember being about seven or eight
years old there was a thing on Sunday
afternoons reruns of old movies one
Sunday there was a movie called the nuns
story with Audrey Hepburn I could not
take my eyes off of it I remember being
so drawn in by it and it was a really
powerful experience watching this story
I started telling people here and there
that I wanted to be a nun and they
thought that I was completely insane but
it was a lot more than that I loved
going to church the feeling of God was
always around me it was very intense
from the time I first remember being
alive I felt God's presence I had a very
difficult childhood my father was a drug
addict and alcoholic and so I grew up in
a home with a lot of domestic violence
and uncertainty economic terror so a
little kid I would pray and that's what
I felt like kept me going but I was also
told that women are supposed to get
married we're supposed to have children
because that's we were made to do I had
a really hard time you know hiding the
fact that I felt absolutely no urge to
get married or have children because
it's not very popular in American
culture to say that you don't want to do
that I certainly like dating I loved
boys I chased a lot of boys and tried to
be a normal person because I was told
that's what you have to do to be normal
but it always felt like I was faking my
personality I would try to be fun my
friends would say oh let's go out
dancing and and I just hated it so by
the time I was in college I was really a
closeted Christian because in college at
least at that time it wasn't very cool
to be spiritual it wasn't cool to go to
church
so I hid it I buried it really deep I
went to NYU I got an acting degree in
1989 I graduated and then I went to Los
Angeles to pursue acting and I knew
pretty much from the very beginning of
trying to pursue acting that I was not
going to succeed because it was all
about put yourself out there and sell
yourself and things that are just
completely not me
so just took a job in advertising to pay
the bills and that job led to a 20-year
career and motion picture advertising I
worked on print campaigns for all the
big movies a lot of my work ended up on
posters for The Hobbit franchise the
Batman franchise The Expendables that
was a really complicated shoot the
people in that job we're making 100
hundred fifty thousand dollars a year
but every time I would drive past the
church every time I would hear something
about God I would think that's where I'm
supposed to be and I think like most
people I felt like I wanted something
more out of my life I wanted something
deeper and more meaningful I didn't feel
like I was doing something meaningful I
felt like I was doing something just to
make money it wasn't until the late 90s
I had been dating a guy for about five
years but he was an atheist and he knew
that I was Christian he knew as a
believer but I really suppressed that I
really pushed it down and he and I got
married and we went on our honeymoon
to Paris and I remember I walked into
Notre Dom with my brand-new husband and
I completely burst into tears because I
was so overwhelmed by the presence of
God if I hadn't been so self-conscious I
would have fallen down on my knees in
the middle of the church and sobbed but
I just stood there crying and my atheist
husband said to me what's going on Mike
what's happening and I thought I still
want to be a nun that's what it is I
mean I just wanted to be with God that's
the only thing that mattered to me it
was almost a relief when I started
realizing the marriage wasn't gonna work
out I started emailing nuns Roman
Catholic nuns and I said to them I
really want to be a nun I felt a calling
for this ever since I was a child and I
tried carrying it in therapy I've tried
being a normal person I've tried acting
like a real woman and nothing is working
it and but the only thing that I'm
having trouble with right now is the
Roman Catholic beliefs on homosexuality
on women priests on reproductive freedom
and I said is there any way that the
Roman Catholic Church is going to change
their stance on any of those issues
anytime soon and it was a Roman Catholic
nun that said to me probably not for the
next five hundred years will those
things change but you sound like an
Episcopalian surely after that I got
divorced and started down the road to
actually joining a community so it took
me 14 years and I visited four different
communities
I felt really drawn to this community
the first time I visited in 2002 so I
joined this community in 2012 I was
received as a postulant I was finally
made it for life profession which is
sort of like getting tenure I got tenure
as a nun last June but it really was the
combination of me wanting all my life to
be something that American culture does
not want me to be I think that we're
told there's only one path to happiness
and I don't think that's true for
everybody I don't think everybody's
called to marriage and children I don't
think everybody's called to the career
path I think people are called to all
sorts of different things and we just
have to let people do what their
authentic self needs to do it's the
greatest joy I've ever had in my entire
life to be my real self to take off all
the masks I had to wear since I was a
little kid to stop trying to fit in be
normal and just being who actually
there's been a absolutely no greater joy
in my life than to to do that kind of
ministry because I think everybody in
the heart wants to do something to make
the world a better place the fact that I
get to do that I get to get up every day
and do that it's just a privilege and an
honor
[Music]